antioxidativ die alkohol ist ungesund
das braucht keiner mehr zu erzählen aber
bisschen alkohol bierchen hier beinchen
da ist das vielleicht sogar gesünder als
gar kein alkohol zumindest liest man
dass ständig schauen wir uns mal die
wissenschaft an
[Musik]
wir kommen bei meine freunde der sonne
ich bin es wieder mal eure chemikerin
des vertrauens wie viele von euch wissen
bin ich eine asiatin die keinen alkohol
verträgt weil mein abbau in zügen kaputt
ist
die hydrogenase allem mit dem gymnasium
2 und wenn ich nicht gerade
wissenschaftlich demonstriere dass mein
abbau enzym kaputt ist hertz fragen ja
lebe ich abstinent ich trinke keinen
alkohol dieses weinglas freunde ist nur
requisite aber vielleicht sollte ich
mich mal fragen ob ich nicht doch ein
bisschen trinken sollte aus
gesundheitlichen gründen es gibt dazu
einige wissenschaftliche studie schauen
wir uns mal eine der neuesten über
alkoholkonsum und demenz an die 2018
rauskommen dann hat sich hierfür über
9000 briten angeschaut die sich in den
80ern dazu bereit erklärt hatten an
einer langzeitstudie teilzunehmen
alle vier bis fünf jahre wurden die
teilnehmer medizinisch untersucht und
unter anderem auch zu ihrem
trinkverhalten befragt mittlerweile sind
die teilnehmer alt genug so dass fast
400 von ihnen an einer demenz erkrankt
sind und jetzt fragen sich die forscher
gibt es einen zusammenhang zwischen
demenzrisiko und trinkverhalten ja hier
sind die ergebnisse
was ihr hier seht ist die sogenannte
hazard ratio aufgetragen gegen die
alkoholmenge rechts geht die kurve
einfach linear nach oben
je mehr alkohol desto höher war auch das
demenz risiko in england ist die
offizielle empfohlene alkoholmenge
maximal 14 alkohol units pro woche das
entspricht dreieinhalb liter bier pro
woche mit dieser alkoholmenge
geht ein gewisses demenz risiko einher
dass wir jetzt hier als referenzwert
nutzen die stärksten trinker waren bei
einer hazard ratio von 3 das bedeutet
das demenzrisiko war verdreifacht sei
wahrscheinlich schon selbst gemerkt dass
die kurve links so ein bisschen komisch
aussieht also erst haben wir so ein
bereich wo die kurve relativ flach
verläuft das heißt in einem gewissen
bereich wo man eh nicht so viel trinkt
gibt es sich nicht viel aber ein
bisschen mehr oder weniger trinkt doch
dann ganz links macht die kurve zum
knick nach oben
und das bedeutet dass leute die gar kein
alkohol treten ein erhöhtes demenzrisiko
haben im vergleich zu denen die wenig
trinken man nennt so eine kurve form
auch j förmige beziehung weil es eben so
ein bisschen aus erwin j und diese
erhöhung da hinten die war hier auch
statistisch signifikant das heißt es war
ziemlich wahrscheinlich keine zufällige
schwankungen für mich als nichttrinker
heißt es jetzt erst mal und natürlich
braucht dieser kleine knick das einzige
was so groß durch die medien ging für
diesen schönen linearen zusammenhang
zwischen alkohol und demenz haben sich
die wenigsten interessiert nein es war
die tatsache dass alkohol abstinenz mit
dieser leichten erhöhung von demenz
risiko zusammenkommt das war die
schlagzeile aber achtung achtung ja ich
weiß ich habe immer noch keine batterien
so viel sagt dieser knick am ende dann
doch wieder nicht aus den menschen die
gar keinen alkohol trinken
die muss man mit vorsicht genießen also
statistisch gesehen und zwar wie leben
wir in einer gesellschaft in der alkohol
ganz selbstverständlich dazugehört wenn
hier jemand keinen alkohol trinkt da hat
diese person meistens sehr spezielle
gründe über mich haben wir schon
gesprochen
bei anderen können andere medizinische
besonderheiten vorliegen zum beispiel
dass sie probleme mit der liebe haben
und nichts trinken dürfen oder dass sie
früher alkoholiker waren und jetzt
trocken sind anders gesagt nichttrinker
unterscheiden sich von trinkern nicht
nur durchs nicht trinken sondern auch
durch weitere
systematische unterschiede die sie
schwer vergleichbar machen das kann man
auch in unserer demenz studie sehen die
gruppe der völligen abstinenzler waren
in dieser studie über das steht nicht
oft frauen mit geringem
bildungsabschluss mit geringem einkommen
die häufig übergewichtig waren sie
schlecht ernährten und wenig sport
machen und das alles sind selbst
risikofaktoren für eine demenzerkrankung
warum mir ist diese faktoren mit dieser
abstinenz zusammenfielen
das weiß man nicht aber so ist die
datenlage normal
es kommt sogar häufiger vor dass in
studien zu alkohol ist diesen linearen
zusammenhang gibt mit j erhöhung hin zu
den abstinenzlern wo man die
abstinenzler aber extra rausnimmt aus
der auswertung weise ebenso schlecht
vergleichbar sind deswegen sagte ich
menschen die gar keinen alkohol trinken
sind statistisch mit vorsicht zu
genießen
trotzdem ist es nicht auszuschließen
dass ein bisschen alkohol für bestimmte
krankheiten von vorteil sein könnte in
dieser studie wurden 83 ähnliche
langzeitstudien gleichzeitig ausgewertet
mit insgesamt fast 600.000 menschen hier
sehen wir jetzt was das ihr vielleicht
auch schon in der eine oder andere
schlagzeile gelesen habt nämlich
teilnehmer die mehr alkohol tranken
hatten ein geringeres herzinfarkt-risiko
das risiko sind zwar nicht beliebig tief
aber mehr ins wert ist es trotzdem also
muss ich jetzt doch zu schauen dass ich
ab und zu ein bierchen trinken
nur wenn ich nichts gegen schlaganfälle
habe denn bei schlaganfällen wurde ein
erhöhtes risiko beobachtet wie auch bei
vielen anderen rund schönen krankheiten
und über diese studie hinaus weiß man ja
auch dass alkohol mit bestimmten
krebsarten zusammenhängt und natürlich
auch mit lebererkrankungen deshalb ist
es nicht verwunderlich dass man hier
feststellte dass alkoholkonsum mit einem
generell erhöhten sterberisiko
zusammenhängt je mehr alkohol desto
früher tod vielleicht nicht unbedingt
durch einen herzinfarkt aber das ist
jetzt nicht der punkt den man für sich
aus dieser studie heraus bieten sollte
vielleicht ist es aber gar nicht der
alkohol also das ethanol an sich sondern
irgendwelche anderen stoff für die gutes
tun
rotwein soll ja so einige wundermittel
enteilt
droht ein kleines molekül namens
resveratrol antioxidativ und jahres
patrol hat bisher in laborexperimenten
also an zellen und an tieren ganz schön
beeindruckende ergebnisse hingelegt als
potenzielles mittel gegen alzheimer
bestimmte krebsarten wir sogar als
anti-aging-mittel doch wenn man sich
deswegen jetzt rotwein rein schüttet
bleibt ja immer noch das problem ist nur
dass es nach wie vor alkohol und
ungesund ist wobei man auch resveratrol
als pulver im internet bestellen kann
aber auch hier würde ich das geld sparen
bevor es nicht klarere ergebnisse aus
klinischen studien mit menschen gibt
aber kann man nicht irgendwie ausnutzen
dass alkohol bei bestimmten krankheiten
das risiko zu senken scheint vielleicht
schon erstmal achtung achtung allem
worüber wird heute gesprochen haben
handelt es sich um korrelationen und
nicht und kausalitäten wenn ihr nicht
wisst was das bedeutet nicht schlimm
es gibt ein ganzes video dazu aber wenn
ihr es alkohol tatsächlich gegen
herzinfarkt helfen würde dann könnten
wir ja trotzdem ich alkohol als
medikament einsetzen wegen oder
unbeliebter nebenwirkungen wie tod oder
anderen krankheiten aber es könnte sich
lohnen heraus zu knobeln in welche
biochemischen mechanismen alkohol hier
genau verwickelt ist da gibt es
interessante hypothesen zum beispiel
verbessert alkohol akut die
blutfettwerte
das könnte auf dauer das risiko senken
das herzkranzgefäße verstopfen wenn man
erst mal verstanden hat was da genau
passiert könnte man einen wirkstoff
entwickeln der nicht so gefährlich ist
wie alkohol aber in denselben
mechanismus eingreift ja doch was auch
immer man noch alles gutes über alkohol
herausfinden wird die gesundheitlichen
benefits werden niemals rankommen an die
gefahren und in dieser form kriegt ihr
definitiv nur beides gleichzeitig
insofern sei es okay eine frage so unter
freunden der sonne liegt es nur an mir
weil ich keinen alkohol trinke oder
findet ihr auch unseren umgang als
gesellschaft mit dieser droge alkohol
fremd vorschlag mache ich mich auf
unbeliebt schreibt es in die kommentare
team vorschläge für neue videos sind
auch immer willkommen wir sehen uns
nächsten donnerstag trinkt nicht so viel
und bleibt sicher ethanol